Speaker 1: Caitlyn Jenner appeared on television
and was asked about the outrageous statements
made by Kanye West, including, I like Hitler and
I like Nazis. And Caitlyn can come up with nothing
more than I wish. Kanye. Well, this reminds me of
another guy we know, which I'll remind you about
in a moment. Here's Caitlyn Jenner defending
Kanye. I'm just saying, Kanye's a good guy.
Speaker 3: I've known obviously Kanye for a long
time. He's always been very, very good to me.
And I just wish him well. I just I won't
continue to do. Have you talked to. Well,
not in the last few months. We're
speculating all this stuff has come
out. I have not talked to him,
but I just wish him the best.
You know, he's he's got challenges and I just hope
I'm the best. Yeah, he's always been very good.
He is a really nice guy. Right? I've been around
him my whole life or for the last ten years and I
just wish him well. You know, I honestly, yeah.
Speaker 4: A lot of people are disappointed and
offended and hurt by it, but now he's landed.
Speaker 3: On it and I get it saying what's
and I don't blame him for being offended that I'm
offended by it. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, but something's
going on here is Kanye. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: So absolutely
electric political analysis there from Caitlyn
Jenner. And by the way, the I wish him well
stuff. I know that this is sort of like apropos
of nothing but it did remind me of when Donald
Trump was asked about Glenn Maxwell, the sex
trafficker, former girlfriend of the late Jeffrey
Epstein. And Trump could think of nothing else
to say other than he wishes her well as well.
Speaker 2: I'm wondering, do you feel that
she's going to turn in powerful men? How do you
see that working out?
Speaker 5: I don't know. I haven't
really been following it too much. I just wish her
well. I've met her numerous times over the years,
especially since I lived in Palm Beach,
and I guess they lived in Palm Beach. I
guess I wish her well. Whatever it is,
I don't know. The situation with Prince
Andrew just don't know. I'm not aware of it.
Speaker 1: Doesn't know anything about it,
guys. Just his wishes are, well, multiple,
you know, accused trafficker of women wishes
her well. So the folks who you would expect to be
struggling to just completely denounce Kanye West
taking several steps back. Well, he's always been
very nice to me or he's a brilliant guy or he's
a really nice guy or yeah, the stuff he's saying
is wacky, but it's just a mental health episode.
We've got to condemn this stuff and we have to
make sure that mental illness or not, it's not
acceptable anywhere. And very interestingly,
by the way, check out the statement made by
Jewish UFC fighter Natan Levy recently. I wish
I had it prepared here. I just don't because I
just saw it and remembered it and okay, I don't
have it. But he was asked about this and he is
taking a much more aggressive approach than many
potentially on it. But we can't look away and it
can't be written off as merely the rantings
of crazy people. That's the important message